what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here my bags are packed for the first
time in four years I'm going to be
taking a trip and I have taken other
trips in the time I've been doing
YouTube but it'll be the first time on a
trip where I'm not going to do anything
YouTube related I feel like I could just
use that for my own personal reasons I
would like to just take at least a week
off from YouTube because even when I've
been to New York I've been to
Switzerland and both those times I was
filming editing uploading live streaming
I'm still doing a pretty good amount of
videos and I kind of just like to be in
the moment and decompress is that the
word John decompress yes I used to write
I used to say decompose yeah so I'm
going to take the time to decompress I
come back with a fresh head and also you
know like I know the defenders is coming
out this weekend and that's when the
wedding is I'm going to so I won't be
able to watch the defenders and review
it when I'm out there I'm going to
Colorado by the way I won't be able to
review it well although you know I won't
I'm just choosing not to I'd rather do
that when I get back so that's going to
be late any reviews or if I decide to do
some type of reaction to a defenders
thing that's going to be a little late
and also Game of Thrones I've heard that
the trailer for the next one was pretty
freakin insane and I'm going to be late
to talking about that one too because I
won't be back to August 22nd in the
evening time hopefully it's a 17 hour
car drive over there so hopefully on
Wednesday I can get back into the fun
filming stuff but I just feel like I
could use a break for actually you know
I could have earned it directly I want
to take one trip without you know being
absorbed by this with a social media and
comments and all that for at least a
week and in that time though what we're
going to be doing to keep the channel
running this mofo right here sup it puts
up things about to change around here
this is the old real Regent
yes it's new real reject starring me
really going to talk about any horror
movies and music it's all day you're
ready but you guys can do John will be
running the channel for the week that I
am gone if you guys would like you can
put down requests for anything you want
John to review talk about I'm assuming
most of you guys to kind of just put to
have a reaction requests and so the jobs
going to take a you know step into my
life for a second
yeah and truth be told I'm a little
terrified written no beta now the people
love you John you're my partner I know
but do what I love myself so yeah guys
I'll be gone for a week 15 to the 22nd
so I uploaded so many videos today and
when I'm back on the 23rd hopefully I
can just hop right back into things Game
of Thrones defender stuff will be late
but John will be here right now keeping
the ship steady it's not gonna be late
I'm gonna watch all of it and season two
of Jared and the defenders and review
all that [ __ ] we connect so little wordy
saying what is TV not sleeping these
days week help us out put down your
requests that way John can make a huge
bunch of screenshots of what people want
him to check out or talk about take care
guys I love you I'm actually I'm a
little tense to be honest is the first
time ever I'm gonna be like I'm going to
be with my phone in social media YouTube
oh my god so I'm a little tense about it
but I feel like because of that feeling
of getting tense I would like to
experience this at least seven days
without it so I can clear my mind love
you guys I'll see you soon